[Applause]
let me give you the epstein deal
yeah epstein like you go to a fancy
restaurant or a fancy hotel
there's a maitre d or there's a
concierge yeah he's just a [ __ ] boy
isn't he he's a [ __ ] boy
and exactly uh this guy's smart that's
why i knew
he was a [ __ ] [ __ ] boy that that
woman was working him right
break that down gizlane maxwell was the
head guy i knew it
i said this [ __ ] way back in the [ __ ]
day i love your podcast
you guys know all this [ __ ] already i
watch but it seems so obvious to me
it's it's because you're smart man but
you know when you're smart it's all
obvious when you're not you're doing
ayahuasca that's
that's that's right no but you know what
it is that's that like that's that's
sexism you want to prove sexism it's
like the the girl oh yeah we're gonna
get to this evil [ __ ]
i think it's women evil [ __ ] it's a lot
of times women run [ __ ]
keep going on this thing they say men
commit 90 of violent crime [ __ ]
women get away with it because nobody
expects i'm not against women i love
women yeah of course i'm just saying
women get their fair share as much as
guys
okay for you a little moment
i'll let you do it in the bathroom
anyways
let's get back to this yeah this is big
yeah keep going so women
well no we all think in society it's the
women's role in these organizations
well we all think of all women aren't
doing anything yeah that's the
women are heavily involved but what's
the question about epstein
well epstein-gillane epstein was the
[ __ ] boy galen was the actual power
broker or connected to the power broker
yeah her job
her dad uh owned like all the big
british media
he was involved in in finally massage
involved
masaab also mi6 and so he was busy like
well everybody keeps bringing it up
they're running this round and finally
get you know israel involved
uh but um he was involved in mi6
he was a big nazi hunter too in world
war ii and
and and and and then all this stuff went
on uh but but but that was the big deal
with with with his like maxwell's was
kind of like
he gets taken out right mossad takes
them out they throw him off the yacht
that's pretty well known right bought a
bit of myself mi6 one of the spy
organizations goes
yeah they threw him off the yacht killed
him yeah and so she was used as a sex
operative
and then epstein is chosen as a sex
operative but
like i'm saying he's like a major deed
of restaurant he wasn't running
he's in nothing there was a bunch of
groups doing this right and then they
would use sex to compromise people
for political control but bill gates
gets involved
meets with him and now they're
corrupting all these scientists because
now that you have the harvard scientists
and all that's on record yeah
now that you have all these groups
involved yeah gates met with him after
after he no but he's not afraid what's
prince charles brothers
he was just cracking young cheeks man
that that's the thing i think that guy i
don't know if he's like
connected to any decision the point is
is that epstein's not the end-all be-all
yes and israel is not the end-all be-all
and the british aren't the noble and
americans of the end-all be-all
and the russians aren't the end-all
be-all and the chinese aren't the
end-all be-all the japanese aren't they
it's it's there's corrupt evil people
that use these systems
of control and as soon as you think it's
one group doing it you're done
it's it's evil it's good i thought it
was aliens
no they're using aliens well let's go
back there are interdimensional
creatures who are not alien because
they're already here
they've always been here you're an alien
dude
you just think we just popped in this
planet um
oh we got brought here you're saying we
got brother oh you think we have brought
here you think that like weird
alexa let's just say this
like you mix monkeys with whatever we
are obviously the whole planet's an
experiment
like this group's over here that group's
here it's all a big game
to see how we kill each other
okay so back to abc and then back to
galen why is it
that and this must be frustrating for
you maybe it's not
why is it there can be so much proof
that a conspiracy is true
and people can believe it to be true and
then just move on
with their lives well here's the deal
what are you gonna do about it
i mean i'm the same way i know all this
stuff i know a bunch of stuff that blow
you totally away
what are you gonna do about it well what
would you do about it well if you were
president what would you do
what is your ideal world hmm
i would tell people to be good because
if you're a good person
doesn't mean you're perfect but you're
not hurting innocent people and you're
not into messing with people that are
innocent
and if you just promote freedom that's
what fixes things it's really an inside
job we have to all ourselves
be better people it meant we're wrong
and then we have to also then
decide to run stuff because the i mean
one person runs it all but i mean
so many good people are like oh i'm in
respective i've got problems i'm not
perfect
almost somebody else is better than me
run things well that's psychos
so i think patriots they're pro-human
that's actually a bar
this is really interesting you're saying
often the people who are good
are too insecure to be in the positions
of power and the people in positions of
power are the [ __ ] sociopaths
they end up getting into not getting
that exactly
interesting so because we're all worried
like all right people's like what are we
doing like
well i don't make a mistake well you
know what i'm not a bad person i'm going
to make a decision
you want to listen to me go ahead
exactly we have to like start making
those decisions
so how do you get a gillane out of here
and what happens to a gelane
like she's just been locked up for a
while right we hear murmurs about a
trial every once in a while and then
nothing happens
and i just sit back every one time and
go is this [ __ ]
just gonna get off and we're gonna be
okay with it well let me say this
i like trump and i did a research on him
to make sure he wasn't involved
with seven florida with epstein but what
got me concerned was
as soon as she got arrested
he said to her i i wish her well oh yeah
and then i was kind of like is gonna
give her a pardon i mean
because i never saw evidence of him
involved in all this but it was a little
bit creepy
and so you're asking this question just
what happens like
she gets off does she go to jail she
can't get off because again like you
said
she was just as bad as jeffrey epstein
probably worse i mean jeffrey epstein
wasn't born
into running sex operations her dad ran
them all the main guys doing it
and so yeah uh uh
obviously she knows so many the british
imagine
the leverage that gave trump
the gizlane supplied
bare minimum women to the royal family
because they're supplying whatever you
want like i've been in l.a i'm not a
drug guy like alcohol
but i've been in like hollywood parties
like with famous people and they're like
that's what going on
like a guy shows up with a briefcase
just pops it open
there's every freaking drug you know
it's the same thing like hey you want
women you want men you want kids
it's like that
you